we found this video which is kind of
interesting this is from back in June
this is while they were trying to figure
out if this bill would get passed here
is a woman who transitioned as a teen
who is now a d transitioner and there's
an awful lot of these people you're not
going to see them on mainstream media
because obviously it goes completely
against the narrative but just the idea
that you're a 15 year old girl who can
take a certain amount of drugs maybe
visually appear as a boy you suddenly
may find that as a 23 year old man your
problems still exists and now you have a
whole slew of other medical problems and
financial problems and spiritual
problems and and much more in any event
here is a woman who transitioned as a
teen testifying against this bill
because she is now detransitioned
foreign
Cole and I am a 17 year old
de-transitioner from the Central Valley
I was medically transitioned from ages
13 to 16. my parents took me to a
therapist who affirmed my male identity
and the therapist did not care about
causality or encouraged me to learn to
be comfortable with my body
he brushed off my parents concerns about
the efficacy of hormones puberty
blockers and surgeries my parents were
given the threat of suicide as a reason
to move me forward in my transition
my endocrinologist after two or three
appointments put me on puberty blockers
and injectable testosterone at age 15 I
asked to remove my breasts my therapist
continued to refer my transition I
attended a Top surgery class that was
filled with around 12 girls that thought
were they were men most are my age or
younger none of us were going to be men
we were fleeing from the uncomfortable
feeling of becoming women
I was unknowingly physically cutting off
my true self from my body irreversibly
and painfully
our trans identities were not questioned
I went through with surgery
despite having therapists and attending
the top surgery class I really didn't
understand all the ramifications of any
of the medical decisions I was making
I wasn't capable of understanding and it
was downplayed consistently my parents
on the other hand were pressured to
continue my so-called gender Journey
with suicide threat
I will never be able to breastfeed a
child I have blood clots on my urine I
am unable to fully empty my bladder I do
not yet know if I am capable of hearing
a child default term in fact even the
doctors who put me on puberty blockers
and testosterone do not know SB 107 is
circumventing States laws that have
needed safeguards in place so my story
is not repeated children cannot consent
vote known SB 107.
thank you you really must understand
this is this is a girl that is a
biological girl who then once she had
some feelings around puberty and as she
said becoming a woman uh they decided to
well they were going to take her breasts
off and Drug her and all of these other
things now she wants out of all of that
having realized that that it it was
either a phase or whatever it might be
and that is not to ignore the point zero
zero zero whatever it is one percent of
people that genuinely are in the wrong
body and then of course you guys know at
least my feelings on this as an adult
you can do whatever you want but
California as a state wants to be able
to take children away from their parents
wants to be able to mutilate children
that's what California wants to do but
this woke policy is not specific
unfortunately to California but it is
now infecting virtually every level of
our federal government and pretty much
all of our national leaders Joe Biden is
exactly the same you may remember before
Joe Biden was president when he was
running when he said if you're a chick
and you're going to jail or you're a
dude and you're going to jail it's not
what's on your birth certificate that
matters to decide whether you're going
to a male or female prison it's what you
identify as and then you know you're not
going to believe this suddenly a big ass
300 pound giant dude is like yeah call
me Mary and then he's raping women in
women's prisons that's really what we're
dealing with right now it's just so
bananas ridiculous